[Applaudissements]
bourgueil en direct tv jeux d'hier qui
fait les week-ends touché toute la
semaine
[Musique]
c'est là
que je dépense rejoindre
en france c'est la guitare
je suis ouvert quand j'étais en galère
panne est à découvert dernière
robert jouera
elle
que tu prends je hais
m
que je rejoins
c'est là
ag jusqu'au petit jour pyjama
précipitent tous sur le mont fuji yama
c'est là qu'ils pensent que je rejoins
qu'avant la défense c'est la
au suivant
tu sais
[Applaudissements]
coc
alors qu'il va
jusqu'au
[Musique]
or m
[Applaudissements]
il
john's canada
non non
bien
à
m
je veux dire merci à la pitié le
français potion de l'été oui c'est le
son qu'on voulait pour cette dernière on
lui a demandé de venir et je voudrais
remercier nabeul parce que c'est un mec
exceptionnel voilà la vérité il a
vraiment fait pour nous parce que vous
le savez ça ils tuent tout cartonne en
ce moment c'est vraiment et il est venu
pour nous et je voudrais dire un truc
c'est que c'est un mec qui a une parole
parce que où ce que voilà on y est il a
au début avec lui wahou début
franchement je vous rappelle moi tu m'a
toujours soutenu donc c'est un plaisir
de revenir matin en amont et voilà tu
vois une telle débute j'étais là
aujourd'hui c'est un monstre en l'air
mais l'ensemble est lavable et moi fait
pour l'heure nap's
[Applaudissements]
c'est un énorme carton
vraiment je suis tellement heureux pour
toi ce que tu ne mérites
c'est un garçon d'une humidité
incroyable il fait ce qu'il aime il fait
ce qui kiffe et tu nous fais qui fait
alors qu'elle est en tout cas merci
beaucoup et on sait la tpu merci à toute
mon nez voilà et single de diamant
merci
la vapeur
[Applaudissements]
c'est là qu'ils pensent
c'est là qu'ils fassent